oh hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report
well let's talk about tea and crumpets
and scones
in london bridge and the crown
stacy well max we are going to get into
some details about the queen and compare
her and that whole royal system to
wall street but first i want to say you
know anybody could essentially now
live with the view say of london bridge
or tower bridge or
you know right along the thames or see
the buckingham palace or live in
buckingham palace because
there's virtual reality now last episode
we spoke to brian romilly about that and
this episode we're going to continue
some of that conversation but one thing
i want to say is we spent this past
weekend
in virtual reality at the magical crypto
conference and
it was quite amazing like for me because
i spent quite a long time in there as my
avatar
what i realized is that i could roll out
of bed and speak in front of a huge
audience
and it was no problem my hair was
perfect i felt
uh you know presentable and then i
realized that
i think with this whole virtual reality
what you'll see
is that humans will go feral
essentially you don't need to brush your
teeth your breath smells fine
in virtual reality your hair looks great
you know your clothes look
fantastic you don't need to buy anything
new you can stay in the same pajamas
year after year
but the structures of civilization
itself
like the actual real estate that holds
together most of our western economies
and all of the derivatives based on
those
commercial-backed securities
mortgage-backed securities
all that stuff all of that will crumble
because you don't need you just need
one little area like this and to live in
virtual reality
oh right so you're talking about two
things there the crumbling
of our reality our infrastructure
and uh castles that were
important in our in the history of
western civilization like we have a
buckingham palace
and also the collapse of the ego as it
were the conscious mind
because we have a super conscious mind
now called virtual reality
so things that we used to be in the
subconscious mind are now going to be in
our conscious mind which will be the new
subconscious mind like we'll have this
subconscious life that we used to call
reality but it's now
unseen by anyone outside of our
immediate location which is never viewed
outside of our immediate self
so you have these two things collapsing
oh coterminous as
i believe you could say the physical
infrastructure
and the mental infrastructure are
collapsing simultaneously
and we are simultaneously giving birth
to a
virtual reality that's becoming
pervasive and interactive
and and quite uh meaningful
and driving the economy well i was a
cartoon avatar you can see it on the
screen right now
and then here's max he was at at the
same conference speaking on stage
you only spent that a half hour on stage
with lena but i spent hours there and
walking around the environment
and finding my way around rooms and even
though it's a cartoon
obviously i felt part of it and then
when i was interviewing dr adam back
i felt like in myself like i was sitting
with him and talking to him so
even at that rudimentary virtual reality
level
i felt that so what's it going to be
like when it gets way more advanced when
we have
more of a mesh 5g network around the
world that could
um basically uh secure
you know and produce uh deeper realities
well i think the point being that you're
making there is that you had that sense
of intimacy
that you would have in a physical space
you had it in a digital space i guess
that's was the
unexpected and that uh you you kind of
like you're thinking now that
you could see this really taking off and
this whole sense of fear kind of
disappears
because i was in the middle of a
conversation with obi nosu actually
and my avatar took off it just started
flying away
and it went over the virtual ocean and
at first i was like oh my i was scared i
was like wow like what if i drop from
here like i'm way over the ocean
and it was kind of scary and i was like
oh no and i was trying to hold on
like you know to what and then i just
relaxed and i was like well i wonder
where i'm going to end up and i did go
through the edge
of this virtual universe and then
like weird diagonal and rectangular
shapes and then
total gray that's one thing that has
always kept people
from achieving is that sense of fear
yes and so in this reality what you're
describing is that you
drop a lot of the fear and so uh
replacing fear is always faith and with
faith comes great
change right i didn't have fear because
i could hit reset
so i could reset and come back as a
different avatar
if i failed on stage like if i died on
stage
like and metaphorically but that brings
me to this real world that
we inhabit where some people do get to
hit recess
some people have no fear because they
can't lose they get a special reset
button
and we see it you know the the
exorbitant privileges given to us
a few people within our economy in our
financialized economy
and we're going to look at the layers of
exorbitant privileges
commercial real estate fallout even
douses the queen of england office
workers are again told to work from home
retailers don't pay rent
uk commercial property owners sink
deeper into the mire
crown estates which manages the queen of
england's portfolio recently wrote down
the value of 17 shopping and leisure
centers by 17 percent
cutting her majesty's net worth by 552
million pounds
as the economist points out this is
fairly small beer
set against the 13.4 billion dollar
evaluation of the queen's property
portfolio which includes some of
london's
toniest real estate and
the thing is that apparently according
to the
2011 sovereign grant act
the overall amount that the queen is
given each year in order to fund her
official duties is never
allowed to fall regardless of what is
happening in the broader economy
so her you know property portfolio
is mostly given to the state she gets 25
of it unless it all crashes then
the taxpayer like she no matter what her
income
doesn't go down she has this you know
fictional
property portfolio that is theoretically
there
that is like kind of pretends that she
exists as a
you know a property speculator and doing
well but
she can't fail the rest of the economy
any
any landlords that are not royal well
they're about to get royally um you know
messed up
let them eat marmite that's what the
queen's saying
boy has anyone ever tasted marmite wow
that stuff will you know burn the hair
off
off a corgi right there in buckingham
palace don't get anywhere near that
stuff
well it's basically like hitting reset
oh it'll reset you all right
oh my goodness right so it's the queen's
put
right so we've learned in the united
states and around the world central
bankers
starting with al greenspan did greenspan
put
bernanke janet yellen j pal what does
that mean that means whenever the stock
market goes down
the central banks bail everybody out and
so there's no risk
there's risk of owning stocks is near
zero for a certain class of folks
and same thing with the queen except
she's tied into property so they created
a similar situation in
great britain for the queen as the
queen's put so she can't lose if she
the value of the property drops she's
reimbursed if it goes up
she keeps the uh proceeds as far as
whether she owns it or doesn't own it
it's the structure is
um similar to what we would find in any
offshore
type of arrangement where wealth is kept
at arm's length and that the folks who
control it have a way to say they don't
control it and
that's very well established in britain
and it's probably the world center for
that
it's also like in the united states so
the queen is the exception to the rule
in a non-reserve currency
country so she gets bailed out her
portfolio no matter
no matter what she herself and her
family get an income
even if their estate their property
portfolio does not
achieve that in the u.s what we have is
the center
you know that is the money printer bank
only the fed can genuinely print money
remember i predicted recently that the
fed will start sending money
to these brits now who are going to have
to work from home because the
you know the bank of england can't print
money like we can and the same thing
with this facade
the charade of you know these uh you
know
captains of industry and these property
barons
and we have a lot of property barons
some of the biggest billionaires in
america are actually just in the
property industry
and including the president right so
here we have a situation where
we have commercial mortgage-backed
securities which again
there in the u in the uk property
portfolios the reits are
being marked down by 50 but in the u.s
they get to stay a hundred percent and
transferred to the
central bank's balance sheet they can't
do that in the uk because they don't
have a reserve currency so in the u.s
there's a certain class of people a
royal sort of class
that they get to always hit reset like
oh
our investment in these commercial
mortgage-backed securities failed
reset and they get to go you know stop
flying over the bubble of catastrophe
and the economy and they get to hit
reset then there are the drags of
society
to 99 that are walking around feral
without any access to this wonderful
virtual reality
for the most part now we have it we're
going to be entering a virtual reality
where they get to hit reset as well
oh that sounds excellent so everyone has
the ability to hit the reset button
soon egalitarianism
and merito erotic democratic um
social constructs that would be an
improvement on the current
constitution of bill of rights which
seems to be getting kind of
chipped away at by special interests so
he can resume the rights of men and
democratic ideals and that type of thing
yeah but you also see the hierarchy of
exorbitant privilege because america has
an exorbitant
privilege of being able to print the
dollar the uk
doesn't have that so they can't bail out
everybody
they've chosen to bail out right now um
commercial property
uh tenants cannot be kicked out they
can't be evicted until december 31st
that's been extended
so any small you know joe bag of donuts
who is not royal does not belong to the
aristocracy
they will not be bailed out so the
landlords are losing
and at the moment like in in the west
end where all the theater is
the shaftsbury estate which is one of
the biggest they're only collecting
41 of rents due have been paid to them
what about the pasty shops in cornwall
that's the key
for great britain's success is a good
pasty from cornwall
well we have to take a break after a
couple of pasties chicken and mushroom
we'll be back with much more don't go
away
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser time now to return to our
conversation with brian
romilly over there voice first dot
expert and around the coin
podcast brian welcome back thank you max
pleasure to be here well you know things
are getting interesting uh
during our previous conversation i just
wanted to pick it up
where we left off and we're talking
about
individual sovereignty self-sovereignty
the ability to monetize effectively
what's going on inside our brains
to the point where instead of just being
swamped with images and data and
requests
to do commerce from outside we then
have our own sovereign self that we can
monetize using something like bitcoin
and interact with this emerging
artificially intelligent digital world
as you see it in a very
constructive way correct absolutely max
i believe that bitcoin and and other
things built on top of the blockchain of
bitcoin uh will allow you to monetize
yourself
and the value that you create not only
when you're living but as you go on
is going to be immense in my
view the beauty of the blockchain is
that there's a permanence to it
it exists way beyond any particular
realm right
so it's very possible that things that
you created
um like the song happy birthday for
example
uh that song was paying uh generations
uh of people even though that song
originally was stolen
for for uh you know at least 100 years
uh
slightly less than 100 years i say the
things that somebody publishes whether
it's
a uh a a novel or whether it's
factual information or whether or not
it's just an image that they took
that you are part of that monetization
process
and you you get to blockchain that stuff
you get to own it and your ai
your artificial intelligence your uh
intelligence amplifier if you will your
personal assistant
helps mediate those types of
transactions
and you can do it in real time you can
do it in delay time so what strikes me
listening to here and
also thinking about bitcoin for a second
so bitcoin
has a network it's saying over 100
quintillion
calculations per second and it's doing
this by co-opting a network
uh people have volunt you know
volunteering their cpu volunteering
their computer hash power
and because they're trying to win the
every 10 minute lottery to get some
bitcoin which now has a monetary
value it sounds to me like what you're
saying is that your brain
is a node and once it's on this
artificial intelligence driven network
you want to get to you will get rewarded
in some way by simply attaching your
braid
to the network and i and
based on what you're saying the ai
which you're having this interaction
with through voice
knows the boundary between who you are
and who the network
is right so talk about that nicely that
membrane if you will that digital
membrane
that separates max keiser from the
network is it porous
is it a hard membrane am i going to lose
myself to the network did my
individuality
become collectivized am i still me brian
what are you doing to me what's
happening
max it's a wonderful question so that's
why i'm really an advocate
of hyperlocal and hyperlocal uh
computing
means that we're going to have petabytes
of data if you were to put a camera on
your shoulder and record everything
you've heard
seen uh everything you've interacted
with you'd be
uh well below a petabyte of data now
today
a petabyte of data costs tremendous
amount of money let's call it
a hundred thousand dollars uh moore's
law and something i
am researching and others have but is
now finally getting picked back up
is uh holographic crystal memory
literally a crystal
can hold a few petabytes of data meaning
all of the context you've ever had in
your entire life
on a small crystal which can't be emp
it literally would have to be crushed to
be taken away
that's never on the internet it doesn't
connect to the internet directly
the hyperlocal concept is if you need to
connect to the internet you create an
agent that agent goes out specifically
does something
for you and comes back with that
information or places information out
there
so there's a lock there's a door and
only information gets slid under the
door
this makes it impervious to hacking and
it gives you
agency over your information and it
can't bear witness against you for a lot
of biometric reasons a lot of people are
going to be listening and saying
oh my god it's everything i've ever done
well there's biometrical ways
to make sure that it doesn't bear
witness against you so
you will have your sovereignty you'll
have your individuality
and you'll have the ability to monetize
yourself in a way that we've never seen
before in society
and it's not utopian it's just
anti-dystopian
a lot of people predict the future of
this you know merging with the machine
and the oneness and we're going to all
become computers
and i uh pretty much say that you know
if you look back in time
during the industrial revolution
everybody always had that dystopian
vision
and i don't believe that humans ever
wind up going in that direction
unless tyrannical government forces make
that happen
and i think ultimately we overcome those
tyrannical forces
so this is about individual liberation
it's about control
of who you are and getting equally for
the first time in history
adequately compensated for the value
that you wind up creating
if you choose to create value the sum
total of this data
is held in uh crystal
data um entities
so i i would imagine therefore the um
the gateway between the two
realms would be using of course
encryption the same way that we use
encryption to
protect our private keys in the bitcoin
space
so on the area of encryption i guess you
should get your comment on this
something that comes up often is well
quantum computers are going to hack
encryption and that's a risk to bitcoin
what's your take on that absolutely
quantum computers will hack
all forms of encryption that's a
guarantee so
at some future point in time whatever
war secrets
will no longer be secrets that's a fact
but that does not necessarily uh make
bitcoin irrelevant
what it does is it makes prior
blockchain uh transactions and
prior government secrets uh well known
so there were things that are that were
put out into the let's put it say put
out into the world
that are going to be de-encrypted
through via quantum computing
and that may happen sooner than most
people think but it doesn't break
bitcoin
because bitcoin would become impervious
by utilizing
quantum uh let's call it quantum
resistant
but let's call it quantum aided uh
blockchain
and it's a relatively easy thing and
there's a number of researchers that
have already come up
with uh rather robust solutions for that
so that's not the end of the world
i think on the other side of the end of
the world is when we start mining
asteroids which is going to happen
it's already starting to happen uh in
the spirit
in a period of next few months we're
going to take
the very first sample off an asteroid
and it's going to come back to earth
and so that's going to be publicly the
first time we've actually mined an
asteroid
and we've been able to analyze the
contents and that's the osiris mission
and that's going to be an interesting
point in time
because that change is what we called
precious and it changes what we call
rare
and that's another street we can go down
but
um all of this is interrelated because
the the only energy that's
really created in the world is is human
creativity and intelligence
and uh and the control of that has
always been
uh throughout history the things that
wars have been fought over uh we think
it's natural resources
but those natural resources are
irrelevant unless we have the creativity
and ambition and intelligence to do
something with it or else you just kind
of
you know what you take uh you take
silver and use what what do you do you
make jewelry out of it it doesn't become
anything
but it could be a photographic plate and
one of these polaroid cameras at one
time
right so that's what a lot of economists
wind up failing at is they just look at
the
the rarity of something but not the
human ingenuity
and the the ai systems that we're
talking about
and quantum computers are emerging at
such a way where
i believe individual human creativity
will
finally have its highest value in the
economy people listening to this
would start to think oh this sounds
pretty uh
you know futuristic but in fact this is
all part of what's happening in real
time today
so let me ask you this why and you can
kind of break it down why this is
happening
all around us today why does siri suck
compared to alexa and there's a lot of
reasons apple
lost its ambition the very last thing
that steve jobs did
uh as far as his uh acquisition
was to acquire siri and he said that is
the next
the next mountain for apple to climb
this can be more important than touch
screens
uh icons and mice ever will be
so steve's vision was to ultimately
create this ai agent
and apple let that die in the vine
amazon
it was built by a a merchant and jeff
bezos is much more aggressive in
understanding how these
agents and that's that's like a text
editor compared to a
full-color icon word processor
we're not even at the beginning stages
of the uh
agent era that we're that i'm talking
about it doesn't require new technology
to be invented
it requires companies to disrupt
themselves
so if you are in the business of say
amazon selling goods or google selling
somebody's contacts and information the
world that i'm talking about
doesn't look so pleasant because it's
quite disruptive
it's disruptive because you have 100
agency
and control over your contents and
context
and that becomes a problem and like all
technology disruption
it's going to come out of a garage
they're going to be groups of people
building this stuff for their own game
and and for their own uh entertainment
like steve wozniak did and steve
jobs did in the garage and ultimately it
will start taking uh its place
but um the old age is already over uh
nobody's downloading apps as much
anymore uh we've reached peak apps so
that economy is sort of
done and uh we're starting to see this
new age rise
uh it's going through a quite uh quite a
bit of a cold winter right now when it
comes to
uh echo and amazon devices
uh but i see that coming back up purely
because they've reached the edge of that
paradigm the idea of downloading an app
into a voice assistant is ridiculous um
i call these things neurons
again it sounds more out there but
basically
a new voice assistant is going to attain
new
capabilities from a programmer like we
do when we learn something new
it's going to be similar to that how you
educate a child for
example is how you're going to educate
an intelligence amplifier and it'll be
with
you for your life it'll be inseparable
uh
and uh that could be scary but i think
if you have control over it it's
probably gonna be like wearing glasses
or having a hearing aid or anything else
uh you become more powerful by having it
let's talk about intelligent life in the
rest of the universe right
i bring this up because the u.s
department of defense revealed that they
had discovered vehicles made of material
not of this earth
uh bizarrely no media really followed up
on this
i don't know if you've been following up
on this it sounds pretty
wild what what do you what can you tell
us about this if anything brian
i know some people that are sort of uh
involved in this i i know tom delong
a uh 182 we've met a few times and
interacted
uh he has to the stars academy and they
are dealing with
uh let's call them alloys and other
types of things
that's publicly being disclosed uh that
thus far look like it has not been made
uh on this planet and it was not made of
a natural process in space
so we're at this point and some of it
has to do with encryption max so we were
talking about
quantum computing and things like that
some secrets are going to be
ex disclosed no matter what this may be
one of them
uh let's just speculate for a moment uh
let's speculate
that we did discover that there are
other forms of intelligence within
with technologies that are not a
thousand years but
a million or two million years more
advanced what would it look like
what would it mean to our society how
did it change our society
i think that's uh that's probably the
biggest question
a lot of us go to the alien side of this
and say well what do
aliens really mean you know what is that
going to mean to society
but that's really not the question i
think that it's going to be asked
is how is this technology dropped a
million years more advanced if it is
discovered
that's all i could say dropped into
society what would it do
uh almost everything we're doing right
now would make absolutely no sense
that's what i'm saying it would make
absolutely no sense uh
almost everything everybody's doing so
that's why it's a critical question at
this moment
okay brian romilly thanks so much for
being on the kaiser report thank you max
i really appreciate it
all righty and that's going to do it for
this edition of the kaiser report with
me max kaiser and
stacey urban want to thank our guest
brian romley you can catch him on
twitter
if you want to catch us yeah do it until
next time bye y'all